josée is with us in Florida hi Joe hey
how are you hi do you thanks for taking
the call
sure what's up um so I'm gonna be
graduating college in May um I have
really great parents that push no debt
or no credit card debt no loan so I
don't have any student loans that were
credit card debt I've lived at home all
of college I was given a $10,000 mutual
fund about ten years ago that has grown
to 16 $70,000 but I was told I can't
touch until I graduate but the one
problem is I just leased a car why would
you do that I don't know okay I forgot
to mention I have about five thousand
dollars in the bank
I'm sorry I also forgot to mention that
I have about five thousand dollars in
the bank
okay so when did you leave the car two
months ago
I want you to sell it how do you do I
believe well you'll have to pay the
difference of what you owe and what the
when you call the lease company who did
you lease it from Oh God okay we'll call
Honda and ask them what the early buyout
is on this thing and then compare it to
Kelly Blue Book of what you can sell it
for and that's how much you're already
in the hole so what was the sticker what
was the sticker value of the stupid but
car and that's RP was twenty seven
thousand oh good lord
and what do you make a year I make it
out twelve thousand year I put forty
five hundred down and my monthly
payments two hundred and your parents
didn't just want to just box your ears
after they taught you better
they're not very happy
she said they follow me for a long time
well I I'm not happy
I don't know how Honda approved somebody
making twelve thousand dollars a year
for a twenty seven thousand dollar car
lease that's just immoral
i I co-signed it with my mom okay um
yeah there's like a whole stack of dumb
things here kiddo I'm not gonna pick on
you anymore
I'm gonna be mean to you but you've got
to get out of this okay it's a mess
you should not have cosign you should
not have least you should not about a
car you can't pay cash for all of these
things are gonna be very detrimental to
you and you graduate when no and what's
your degree in I'm gonna be going to
marketing good okay cool
okay so we'll get out and get a good job
and so the way to get out of this is you
call Honda and you ask them what the
early buyout is meaning if you were
going to pay off the lease in one fell
swoop what would it be my guess is it's
probably gonna be twenty-five twenty-six
thousand dollars okay mm-hmm and then
you look up on Kelly Blue Book kbb.com
for private sale of what you can sell a
two-month-old Honda for and I hope that
is close to 26 or 27 thousand dollars
let's pretend just to give you an
example how the numbers work that the
early buyout is 26,000 and you find the
value to be 23,000 you would sell the
car to someone for 23,000 you would take
3,000 out of your checking account your
savings account and pay the difference
and get out of this mess you've already
taken a hit that every day that you stay
in this thing is going to be a deeper
deeper deeper hole so when I take three
out of my savings on to left well I do
for another car ah you get a hoopty
until you get out of school and you got
the 16,000 and your mutual fund the
mutual fund is is just morally do what I
even touch for fun if you can you get to
it now I can't any other I kind of
wanted to not touch it yeah I kind of I
kind of wanted you to not lease a car or
two and get your mother to co-sign a car
for $27,000 when you make 12 so yeah
you've got you you know this is going to
cost you the bad news is you've made a
huge mistake the great news is you'll
never have to make it again and you're
young and you got this mistake behind
you I've done so many stupid things and
still made it and you
we'll be okay long-term so take three or
four thousand bucks out of your mutual
fund and buy a three or four thousand
dollar car after you get rid of the
Honda but I would get rid of this car
you in the checking I'm sorry
Thank You Patrice the two grain in the
chicken yeah yeah I mean fine fine
whatever you got to do get get your
little car or some kind you don't go buy
a $15,000 car or your mutual fund go buy
two or three thousand dollar car for
cash it's you know it's not real pretty
but that is very reliable and you get
rid of the $27,000 on the lease
co-signed by your mother bless your
heart